with promising career opportunities it's
great time to become data scientist the
field of data science is seeing abundant
opportunities
companies now know the importance of
data the main job of data scientist is
to collect process and analyze the data
before moving forward please make sure
you subscribe to our channel and press
the bell icon to never miss any updates
from simplylearn
one fundamental thing that a data
scientist must know is
statistics before learning any other
programming language you must have a
thorough understanding about statistics
a data scientist need to have
understanding about
variance mean and mode there is no
requirement to learn complex statistics
start with basic statistics
along with this a data scientist must
have idea about statistical optimization
on top of that you should have basic
understanding about linear algebra and
calculus
data analytics it focuses on summarizing
data in a meaningful way this area of
data science makes use of reducing
methods to extract data anticipate the
future and identify trends both machine
learning and traditional statistics are
included in this tools data analytics
includes featured engineering and also
data wrangling programming languages you
need to know some important programming
language as a data scientist the time
period required to learn a programming
language may be from one month to two
months but it is mandatory to know some
of the important programming language
that i am mentioning below
python is the best programming language
for any data scientist it is easy to
learn as well python is implemented in
developing machine learning algorithms
sort and categorized data
r is a prominent language in the field
of data science r enables the design of
several statistical models statisticians
use them to perform regression
java is a favorite programming language
for any developer java machine learning
is used to implement machine learning
algorithms popular java libraries are
used in data mining machine learning and
deep learning
we need to use different ide for
programming best ide for python is
pycharm and also visual basic code best
one for r is rstudio and for java you
can go for eclipse netbeans etc please
install all the software in your
computer system and start practicing
data visualization the graphic display
of information and data is called data
visualization you must know certain
tools involved in data visualization
that includes tableau
one of the widely used software for data
visualization tableau offers interactive
visualization solution for more than 53
000 companies it has excellent
visualization capabilities other tools
like matpolip google charts and c bond
can also use for data visualization
web scrapping web scrapping is the
process of extracting data from websites
data scientists apply this technique to
extract data from different websites you
can scrap data from any ecommerce
website like amazon flipkart mantra etc
and use it for your
projects
a data scientist must have general
understanding about it
tools like scrappy scrappy is an open
source platform
and it is used to extract data from
website it is easy quick and compatible
this is something that every data
scientist must be familiar with next
comes pars hub parser base used by data
scientist for research it is a powerful
visual based web scrapping tools which
enables everyone to create their own
data extraction workflows
next comes beautiful soup beautiful soup
is not a tool it is a library to extract
data from different sources it is a
python package used to pass
html and xml text
machine learning automatically generates
and evaluates enormous amounts of data
without involvement of human beings it
automates data analysis and generates
predictions in the present as a data
scientist you need to learn every
machine learning algorithms thoroughly
and understand the importance of it
five major steps involved in machine
learning are data collection it is the
first step
it is crucial to get accurate and
pertinent data because the quantity and
quality of the data have a direct impact
on how well your machine learning model
performs
data preparation
second step is data preparation
data preparation is a crucial step in
getting suitable data for analysis data
preparation ensures that there are no
incorrect or inaccurate data points in
the data sets training the model the
output value is predicted using the
training data set next comes evaluation
of the model model evaluation is the
process of using different evaluation
metrics to understand a machine learning
model's performance as well as its
strength and weaknesses
lastly prediction
now that your model is trained and
evaluated it doesn't mean it is perfect
and it is ready to deploy the model is
further improved by using different
parameters
for better understanding how to use all
this subject we can take up a use case
we can take up a use case of taxi
vehicles a taxi service company like ola
can use gps to track the position of
their vehicles in order to perform
optimization of parking
based on the number of vehicles ola caps
can redistribute the cars in advance
each new ride is assigned to different
vehicles this is implemented using
statistical analysis for data extraction
we can use their site and implement web
scrapping with different tools like
scrappy and libraries like beautiful
soup we can take up data set of vehicles
and perform data analysis also for data
visualization we can use madpolyp or
tableau in order to cluster machine
learning algorithms can be implemented
in this process
thank you happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here